welcome to the how to use this downtime
to better understand and engage your
employees webinar
i am michelle from the design symbol
council this event
is proudly brought to you by the council
in partnership with the curious people
solution
tcps for short a strategic design
consultancy since we're still
waiting somewhat let's um let's do a
quick poll in the room right now
i think we have about 53 people uh
streaming in on the on the call so this
would be a really intriguing
opportunity to find out what's
everyone's take on this question it'll
be out for 30 seconds so we like to see
what's everyone's answers will you
choose an empathetic employer over a
less empathetic one who pays you more
these are the final results we have 37
of you voting for totally that means you
will choose an empathetic employer over
a less empathetic one
okay fair enough that's what i'll do as
well uh and we have
a whopping more than half 58 voting for
depends
so i think there's also a lot of other
factors that we will be
uh weighing upon when it comes to
choosing an employment of our choice
so i'll let the speakers share more
about that later
all right i think with that i'd like to
hand over the session to
alfred and ken who will be the main
speakers for today's empathy session
hello everyone hello guys so i i'm ken
here yes i'm alfred okay i hope uh
you have a very good morning and uh
thank you so much for those uh
who are joining us uh from overseas uh
i'll start by sharing uh
a very meaningful quote from uh one of
our favorite celebrity oprah winfrey
okay so leadership is about empathy and
of course empathy is about having the
ability to relate
and connect with people for the purpose
of inspiring and empowering their lives
so we feel that this is a very very
powerful quote regarding empathy
it's about people it's about empathy is
being needed in our everyday life
and most importantly uh empathy is a
good bring about good impact for
ourselves and also people around us
so i'll come in to talk to you about the
power of empathy
i'd like to share with you some very
very interesting statistics
okay now uh well uh this statistics is
done by
the the um in the u.s company it's
called the state of workplace empathy it
involves 1 000
employees what will happen when a
company takes care of its people
the first thing that comes out here you
can see now
what happened is 93
of the employees are more likely to stay
with the empathetic and
lawyer so you can see how powerful and
empathy is so if an employer or company
is very empathetic they are likely to
save them
so there will be less attrition rate
okay now
this is the interesting one now just now
we conducted a poll right that's related
to this
like lecture review based on the u.s
survey
78 of the employees actually will choose
a more empathetic company
over a less and protected one that pays
more
so what what do we have just now the pro
that we have here very interestingly
we have about 40 percent of people will
totally be choosing a more empathetic
employer over a less empathetic one who
pays more
then for singaporeans about sixty
percent of us is on uh sitting on the
fence it depends
not deciding yet but interestingly only
five percent will not
will not do so okay so i think this is
also very interesting results from the
poll that we have taken earlier on uh
for us for our singapore
for the whole result we have about 40
percent will totally choose a more
empathetic
employer compared to five percent so i
suppose that about eight times
eight times of them right will actually
consider totally they will consider a
more empathetic employer
realign yeah i'm pretty aligned of
course uh we have about 60 percent
they're still
thinking depends but if you compare the
two extreme case uh
it's pretty obvious that uh about forty
percent of them compared to five percent
who would choose the empathetic employer
now
let's go on to even more interesting
statistics i think this is something
that you may be very interested in what
about working longer hours
now actually based on the survey 78 of
the employees are actually willing to
put in more effort they
are willing to put longer hours if you
are empathetic towards them
now we go into one more interesting one
even you make them work harder and you
are unable to give them
more money due to a certain crisis a
certain situation what will happen
if 60 of them will stay with you guys if
you are empathetic to them
so i think this should really show the
power of empathy we see that if a
company takes care of these people what
will happen
very importantly the people will also
take care of the company
so i think it is right important
especially when there's crises
and situations like kobe 19 right now
with this statistics
it's quite clearly that empathy do have
a certain power with the current
copenhagen situation this next one is a
lifo
how has kovit 19 affected your
employee morale okay shall give you some
time
uh to take part in this poll we have the
poor results coming in uh
five percent stays is not affected uh
seven percent sorry my mistake 74
somewhat affected and very affected we
have about
19 percent yeah basically i think the
major majority about 93
will be affected of course 17 more very
very affected
so what does it mean in terms of uh
empathy empathy is even more crucial
at this point in time i think we can all
agree then when the employees morale is
low and there's a point whereby we
really really need to be more empathetic
and show more empathy
yes right that's okay especially so when
we are so far apart you know we are not
uh we do not have the luxury of being
physically near each other
the only thing that we can ever portray
or convey or show
is empathy through through our online
methods right here we have a quick
case study uh a real-life actual case
study
um with a situation regarding
kobe 19 that empathy was applied and ken
will go
through in singapore uh we are very
aware we have this little situation here
where we have uh the coveted situation
and of course uh involve our migrant
workers
so we can see here there are some
pictures here now in the beginning uh
when we put the migrant workers in a
quarantine
the government agency will be providing
food for them dedicated food for them
and this is a minor problem that
occurred in the beginning
some of the pictures right here we can
see some of the food that has not been
consumed and been thrown away
now this is the problem that our
government agencies were facing in the
beginning
and we'd like to share with you how our
government agency uses
empathy to solve this problem now what
our government agency did was this
they do a deep dive really into the
migrant workers
trying to understand their needs before
this problem can go away so what what
did they find out
now first they found out that the
migrant workers eating habits are very
very very different from ours
they prefer to eat a lot of rice and
also
gravy is very very important to them now
there's actually drastically quite
different from
what a typical singaporean would eat for
example for myself
i think about it uh where i got order
food i usually eat less
rice and less noodles for example but
the micro workers they like to eat lots
of rice and actually
gravy is extremely important there and
they also found that eating habits
is difficult to change it cannot be
altered overnight
so there's a very important finding that
the government agency found out
some migrant workers has been here in
singapore for many years
let's say about 10 years so for me
myself
without these insights without the
empathy in sex i may also think that oh
no if the migrant workers be here for
many years surely they will be able to
get used to our cuisine right
but little did we realize that with the
empathy study it revealed that
all the workers they are working really
really hard and
they got very little resources in terms
of their financial resources
and also the the time resources so they
do not really have the resources to
explore the different cuisine even
they've been here for many years
so they are only exposed their original
eating habits so the eating habits will
not change so with these
very very important insights right you
found a basis for
all the other companies besides the
government agency
all the other companies from the fmb
sector from the catering sector
to come together to co-create delights
for the
foreign workers or for the migrant
workers they started come up with
ways of cooking a lot of rice using
machinery to cook rice
and of course other owners from the fmb
come together to satisfy the needs that
are being uncovered in the empathy study
and come up with very very interesting
bento which
not only focuses on nutrition quality
but most importantly
focuses on the eating habits of the
foreign workers understanding what they
like to eat
i guess this is the most important part
finally of course
our migrant workers get a very happy
meal experience
i think to us a meal experience is very
very important especially when they're
all
koopa they're all in a quarantine milk
become a highlight for them
so they will be looking forward to this
meal when they have been
in the quarantine session and of course
you know food is
always about comfort a sense of
a sense of belonging and so forth this
whole
little the case here uh we have
illustrated to you that empathy
is very very important in solving any
problem so
if your career empathy study properly in
the beginning
that forms a very important basis
whereby everybody
from the government agency from the
companies from the different industries
they can all come in and then work on
the
findings from the empathy study and come
up with different different ideas to
bring up a good experience
the next slide deals with something
being in singapore and now we are going
overseas global
and mnc such as uh the walt disney
company
has actually beginning to rethink about
uh
empathy within the organization
especially
in their leadership development programs
this is this is very critical so this is
one of the things that um
we have also uh ascertained that are
being aligned as well
not only just on a local context but
also globally
so i think now we have established that
empathy is very important all of you
guys are excited
yes so how do we start so we'd like to
chat with you guys
okay do you use an employee engagement
survey to understand your employees
okay this is a simple yes and no poll so
we want to understand from the
from the audience for the participant do
you do that so when you think about
understanding your employees
is that what you use to understand your
employees so we have slightly more than
half about 60 percent of you guys
use engagement survey and are familiar
with engagement survey for this
engagement survey is a quantitative
questionnaire
whereby you'll be asking questions and
of course that will be recorded in a
quantitative way okay
now we'd like to share with you that for
engagement survey
the main point about using engagement
survey is about
measuring and monitoring pre-determined
dimensions that you want to understand
or you want to measure
so this is slightly different from what
we're going to introduce to you because
uh if you really want to understand your
employees
you must find out things about your
employees find out what they like
what makes them happy and follow their
pinpoint so we'd like to introduce to
you something that is beyond
engagement survey that is exploratory in
nature
which is also not a quantitative
approach
it will be more of a qualitative
instrument such as this
does not really have an empathetic
element
in it you know it's basically about
measuring it doesn't really allow
your employee to say what's in their
heart or what they
what truly matters to them there's
nothing bad about this survey or this
instrument
it's just that it's not the um the
appropriate one the objective of this
will be for
measuring and monitoring so if you
really want to find out things and you
want to explore
and find what is the pinpoint the
employees and so forth
we could introduce to you our three t's
empathy study
that allows you to dive very deeply into
the employees need
to really uncover something that is an
underlying needs of the employees
so it's actually one of our proprietary
tools
that we have created and we used it
primarily
in all our projects with our clients in
singapore
it is uh used mainly in this uh portion
and of course you can see that there's
many more other tools but today
we are focusing on this tool and
eventually
we will show you uh something very
exciting how we can apply it
here are the principles okay behind this
toolkit
the the first uh principle the reason
why i call it 3t is because it's
actually
uh about triggers okay it's about tails
and finally it's about truth now to make
it clearer for you
we got illustrated with a business case
how a trigger does involve a
capturing experience using artifact or
photos
and of course tales involves
storytelling which is very important and
finally
based on all the stories right we will
see what are the overlapping stories
that results
that revealed to us was the truth and uh
this
company that we are showcasing is a
local company in the healthcare sector
that takes care of hearing
and we have a few branches spread out in
singapore so
uh we are not able to share the uh
identity of this company because this uh
this project is still ongoing
so we will show you quickly how we can
apply the treaties in a very
simple but uh very impactful way yeah
the first one is this so we get about
all together we get a sample about 10
employees to participate in this study
okay
now each of the employees are asked to
just take five photos
about their good and bad working
experiences
okay so any five photos very simple
because i think nowadays we are all very
uh visual driven we like to post photos
on
facebook or instagram so take five
photos regarding good
or bad experience now the second thing
we get them to do for each of the photos
very simple
okay so they'll write some statements
about their experience
so they can write three statements for
each photo uh if they need a little bit
more instruction we
thought we'll get them to write about
anything about people that in the photo
about any objects that appear in the
photo environment
messages or services so this is a
framework from
our business design thinking framework
it's called poems
so basically they are all the different
dimensions that will contribute to
experience just to have an easy way to
remember it you know these are all the
elements
that will enable you to create a poem
finally with all the pictures and all
the statements that they make right all
the stories that they share with us
we will be able to uncover the truth the
truth will be involving very interesting
involving photos and involving our
statements yeah all together we
collected 50 photos and 150 statements
that is already very rich
should i view the process all right
these are some of the photos are
submitted to us
correct so uh for example we may have a
photo putting here
what would they say they will say oh you
know the workspace
is very untidy very disorganized
very very difficult to find things that
they need
then they may have some comments on you
know the storage area for their stocks
whether they are
organized properly whether is it in a
first in first
out kind of inventory
management and of course uh paperwork
you know how much paperwork the top
paperwork is there any redundancy
in terms of uh doing some work process
besides work guess what they will be
also talking about
celebration and so forth okay so
these are all the different pictures now
once we get all the statements what do
we do
this is the needs analysis portion the
statements are all
entered very very systematically into
access spreadsheet
and we'll start coding it okay by coding
it we are actually grouping the
statements
okay so for example the green one
they're all regarding environment
uh cleanliness and so forth so by doing
so we are able to group them we call
that clusters
so each of the clusters form a very
important need
regarding the employees so the first
round of clustering is to class
transfer them according to points
meaning uh whether is it about people
or objects or environments or messages
or services
then the second round of clustering will
be clustering
according to the uh in terms of whatever
that appears
you know the dimensions that appears in
the statements okay for example this one
no cleaner in the office or
that perhaps would be talking about
cleanliness so
we would then code that as a cleanliness
we'd also have to bear in mind that
sometimes some statements do contain
two data points so that is when we have
to break that statement
up into two data points so these are the
little
uh you know tedious work that we have we
will have to do
but uh that's that will then allow us to
cluster them
by individual data points so we'd like
to just share with you
just some ideas how how the back-end
back-end analysis works but
of course more exciting the more
exciting part is to share with you
after this so this is what we're going
to do
with so normally in a project we will be
the ones doing this
okay our team will be the one doing this
but however there are some
um there are some projects where the
clients would like
to be involved in this process so then
there's this transfer of knowledge
so that it becomes a core uh
participative
uh kind of uh work there so what will
happen is
there will be some training involved
where we would train
a task force from that com our clients
company
and then we would do it together this
way we get to transfer the knowledge
and further down the road in future they
may decide to do it on their own if they
like to
so after that the most interesting part
will be
revealing the needs right now after that
process the end product is something
like that
yeah so the first part of course we're
able to find out one very very big
cluster called the leadership there's
some needs regarding the
leaderships right now now within it we
can even have some dimension regarding
the leadership part it may be
involving needs for open communication
constant feedback and so forth
now besides this big cluster there are
many other clusters
so another cluster involving
collaboration needs and of course they
can look at the different dimensions
inside that supports collaboration needs
and most importantly is these two needs
are actually related in some way
so if you do the leadership needs
somehow you can also be
able to deal with uh the collaboration
needs among the employees
and we can review many many other needs
of course there's some needs regarding a
physical environment right just now it's
not the pictures
uh we have other needs that is regarding
the job itself that may involve some
job redesign and so forth and of course
most importantly there's a very
important need regarding empowerment
of those needs sums up and supported the
need to empower them to serve the
customer better in terms of
personalization and in terms of fast
service delivery
and the photos that we received earlier
on remember
what happens to them well they are not
lost they are not thrown away
now this is where they come back in
action again and they give us a
full visual picture you know
and paints uh the the picture clearly
for us
uh words and the corresponding pictures
from
for so in this case straight away we get
to see what actually
it looks like you know for the various
clusters
of course this is just an example and
also the next powerful thing about this
employee needs map is that
it is interdependent as you can see
leveraging on this principle
you now get to realize that um a
particular need is not
uh uh by itself independent it is
actually interdependent with various
other needs
that is very critical very powerful
something that
promotes uh teamwork and and and
collaboration as well so for in order
for one
to work there's something else in the
puzzle that needs to
be in place you know from here also
leadership as well as employees get to
see
in one clean suite who stands where
what is needed and of course this is a
very important starting point before uh
any kind of ideation or any kind of
solutioning i can can start
okay now the next business case uh uh
will
showcase how empathy is applied with
customers
early on was with employees so now it's
with customers yeah you can go one step
beyond
yes the exact same principles can also
be applied to customers
and the linkage being that employees are
actually
we like to call them our internal
customers
so we must first apply empathy on our
internal customers
so get them in the motion out of things
so then it creates a very great impact
on the customers external customers
to showcase uh this principle uh
we are going to share a business case of
one of our clients as well
and this particular client is a local
cafe
um there is a they have 30 outlets
spread out in singapore and it's so
a subsidiary of our trade union congress
in singapore who looks after the food
sector okay quite a major one and
because of
embracing design thinking in their
process
they managed to um be awarded with
singapore service class
certification in quite a record time so
the principles again
are same the three t's right however the
mechanics how we apply it's different
now you can see of course uh the major
framework is a
very good framework and it's very
flexible now for this fmb establishment
they're going to take five photos again
for the diners basically uh we have
mystery diners eating at the restaurant
uh they are given a certain amount of
money they have
able to buy whatever food they want to
buy and then of course along in this
process they need to take five photos
about their good and bad experience
again but this time is regarding their
dining experience
so similarly they'll take five photos
and then of course
for each other photos what did they do
again they tell us the stories
they will just write three statements
regarding their good and bad experiences
and of course the process goes the same
we will be
clustering or so-called coding the
statements
and find finding out what underlying
libra needs we want to make sure that we
capture
outlets in the heartland area as well as
in the central business district area
we also make sure that we capture their
experiences during peak hours
and during non-peak hours during
weekdays
as well as during weekends so it was
pretty comprehensive
i'm representing and towards the end of
this uh two weeks
we collected 283 photos
and 886 statements yeah yeah so this
will be quite different from
quantitative
kind of approach where you collect data
points and then of course
the presentation is in terms of bar
charts and so forth right yes that's a
qualitative approach
you get statements you get emotional
codes and also you get photos so you can
see this is very very interesting
right these are all the photos that our
our diners took
when they get on to the cafe this is
important because we can actually see
through the eyes of our customers when
they come to our cafe
rather than what we want them to see
many at times that they see what they
want to see like
there are many things we don't want them
to see unfortunately they will also see
okay so this is a very insightful to us
so here's some examples
you know of a photo and a statement that
was uh taken
and given to us submitted by the
customer so i'd like to share with you
how we actually found some
new discovery for example now uh
regarding the clean and organized
environment of course this is something
that uh that
the customers are looking looking at or
they're focusing on
when they come to our cafe okay
originally before this uh
exploratory research right our cafe
owner of course focused on cleanliness
regarding what the dining area
okay that is their main focus they only
keep the dining area extremely clean
but with our exploratory survey we found
out that besides dining area
while the customers are very concerned
about actually the area as well
what do you mean by work area you can
see right here picture a
right regarding the picture a basically
when they start ordering their food
they will be looking at the wood area
meaning the area whereby the cashier is
where they have the receipts where how
they arrange their plastic bags
they may even peek into the kitchen if
they can to see how the utensils are
organized and so forth
we realize that actually cleanliness of
environment
they actually look at the work area and
decide whether is it clean or not clean
and that is already decided even before
they walk onto the dining area
so this is some very important discovery
because
cleanliness now has two dimensions
besides the dining area whole area is
important
but why is this important because before
this discovery then our
cafe owner is very focused on cleaning
the dining area
and they forgot about the work area
resulting in
very very disappointing ratings customer
ratings inc
regarding cleanliness okay so to improve
the rating for cleanliness
if you do not truly understand what the
customer is looking at
uh is unable for you to do solar right
okay
now picture c very interesting picture
what we did was we enlarged all these
photos
and we used it as a training materials
with
the employees and during the training we
did it as a game
we asked employees to pick five photos
each
and from each photo tell us if there's
anything wrong
or if there's anything right if um the
photo depicts
things that are right please share with
us why is it right
or why is it wrong right so an employee
actually
selected this photo uh it was a
supervisor in fact
so what she she what she said was wow
this is a very a nice picture the staff
are very good what they did was they
managed to
keep the tables clean um the floor is
clean as well
no dirt no rubbish and
the trolley was folded nicely neatly and
stacked
one side and the dust bin wow they even
bothered to
be disciplined enough to clear the
rubbish as well as change new trash bag
and then she also commented about the
stack of boxes of mineral water bottle
that was nicely stacked at the corner
you know so she says overall this is a
good picture
so but when we shared the statements
with the with them
so c is just one of them they were all
shocked
that it was a total opposite but because
in the customer's eyes
the customer uh so the customer
mentioned that you know uh when i walk
into your cafe
you greet me with a dustbin this is
actually not a
good picture in from the eyes of the
customer
and some customers even commented things
like this the trolley
and the broom should not even be seen it
should be kept
and then there was a some customers who
always come during lunch time they would
whenever they sit on this seat they
commented that oh
it's very narrow very cramped you know
um they will always get disturbed by the
stuff coming behind them
uh to take uh mineral water to be to be
sold you know that was very something
very irritating
so they were all very short you know for
the first time
ever uh seeing and hearing from the
customer's eyes
so i'd like to add that of course this
is very powerful in in the sense that uh
the employees perspective uh is always
different from the customer's
perspective
so uh if employees cannot empathize with
the customer itself
they are unable to deliver the required
experience so that's again
uh just the first step of everything yes
okay with this understanding i think uh
it's half the better been worn because
with this understanding all the
employees later on you can see
they're able to put in their ideas like
able to put in the effort
to actually deliver the customer
experience so when we checked
with the previous ownership looking
through their sops
and uh the sop did say things like you
know
uh items such as dust such as the
trolleys or the boxes of mineral water
should be kept in the pantry
however why is this still occurring well
you know over time uh rush hour
and overtime you know out of convenience
people tend to get
used to things and over time you know it
just
morphed into this kind of a state yeah
so
it is good uh from for from time to time
that we
we conduct studies like this on our own
of course you know from companies who do
not have the expertise to do
to conduct such an exercise of course
they can engage us
but uh uh for some other other of our
clients
where we we do a transfer of knowledge
they can then
uh perform this exercise on their own
which is something very powerful and
very critical actually
yeah for the employees to have empathy
on the customers
yeah and through these photos ken was
able
then to also apply empathy on the
employees because he
then went to conduct some short
interviews with the employees you know
why is this occurring so that's where
they managed to
tell you that there was some space
issues or something right
yep okay so i think these pictures
actually uh reveals a lot of underlying
uh problems that can be solved in terms
of uh the cafe
design whether space is designed
properly for storing inventory
of course you can see we have some
inventory problem whereby
all these things are being put in the
dining area
of course some storage problems as well
so to begin with is that enough storage
plate space and so forth
so this was a trigger that we were
talking about and this trigger
elicits lots of tales not only from the
customer
but from the employees the employee
starts to tell us oh
why this is happening because of space
issues
oh because they order too much or
perhaps when the order
things get sent to them too early things
like this
so this is what we mean by the trigger
and the tales
and the truths come out those photos
are not do not end there do not get
thrown away after that
what we did was we then used this with
management
we helped them to cluster the photos
early on we clustered the statements
right so now we cluster the photos
and then we sequence the cluster to form
a customer experience journey map
now this is a very powerful experience
journeyman
because it is done created in the eyes
of the customers
through their photos right and
it is organically created can you
imagine that and look at this
all these yellow sticky notes these are
the new touch points
the new touch points that the customers
are telling us that they wish to be
touched
versus the previous journey map which is
created
by management in the office
assuming or presuming that's where they
would like to be touched
right and what's more powerful this all
these pink
sticky notes these are the common uh
problem areas
where we receive a lots of complaints
okay so we we got the management to
write it out
and then paste and paste it where they
are as you can see most of them occur in
the
in the front part now from these
complaints
we were then able to see the statements
from
actual customers and the corresponding
pictures
so for for the very first time we get to
see ah
this is why you are experiencing this
problem this
is how the problem looks like and from
there
immediately we were able to come up with
new solutions
the orange sticky notes were the new
solutions in terms of maybe
uh improved sop or
a new standards and stuff like that so
from so this is this is the power of
doing it
in a qualitative empathetic way
right and of course here you can see the
management doing it
can is here okay and from this journey
map
okay what we do is we have to look in
it's very important to loop it but when
we looked it
it gives us another interesting tool
it creates a tool we call a cycle of
needs
this is very important because this
is the thing that will keep your
customers coming back
because it keeps them in the loop so i
think we have shared with you some of
the ideas about
when you have pictures and how you're
going to use the pictures
or how you can use the data points okay
and over here
what we did just now was the actual
customer journey map
after we have done some ideation
some refining and some iteration and we
prototype the
new processes in the end what we get is
this the ideal customer journey map
with everything laid out nicely now this
will become
the new service standard the blueprint
that everyone in the organization will
be very crystal clear
so that's the difference between the
actual customer journey man and the
ideal customer journey
this is the standard that everyone
should uh benchmark themselves against
yeah remember we just now use the
empathy study on customer right
uh the good byproduct or the good thing
that we'll bring about will also fact
that uh it results in empathy for
empowerment
so through that we are also having uh to
involve
all the employees in terms of the
co-creation of the
new improved service initiative
standards and so forth
so they have a lot of involvement and
that itself is a form of engagement
yeah as you can see in this photo that
was what we were talking about
um this this company has got 136
front line employees spread out across
30 outlets
so um so they were on rotation and we
took
almost six half days to
go through the sessions with them
everybody was it was involved
everybody had a chance to look at all
the pictures that the customers
took as well as their statements and
what we did
was we get the employees to tell us
why the customer is facing this problem
why
they themselves are facing this problem
why they
themselves are unable to deliver this
thing that the customer wish so they are
now
the ones telling us you know what's
affecting them
what's hindering them what's obstructing
them
so what we did was we video captured
everybody's
input everybody suggestions and from
there
they themselves created their own new
and improved service initiatives and
this was
one of a quick a very easy sop that was
created
for them buy-in was fantastic
you go because and uh the change
management was so
easy um especially with this company
they have lots of lots of legacy
workforce
and they embrace it very very much and
here you can see
the pictures do not stop there now it is
being embraced by everyone
in the organization across all functions
across all departments in um how it
guides them
in in their work their new solutions
all centered around employees and their
customers so we like to share with you
of course i think all businesses they're
very
they're very interested in quantifiable
measurable impacts right
so through this whole process about
showing empathy to your customers
sharing empathy to employees what will
happen
now for our one case uh we have this
part you see the employees results
better retention again 93 of them
60 improvement in terms of staff
attrition
and of course there will be very very
high improvement in terms of the
employee engagement
remember alfred did share how the
employees was totally
involved in terms of designing the sop
the service dentist and so forth uh that
that results in a lot of empowerment
and of course it results in a lot of
engagement and of course when we have
the employee result what happened
uh you can see also right because
everyone did share with you as well how
how the pictures and the customer
perspective bring all the different
departments
all the different business activities to
work in sync
that result in operational results okay
you can see all
the operating operational results right
here for
for those who are from overseas nea
stands for
our national environmental agency and
this grading is for cleanliness
in fmb outlets okay so you can see we
have a lot of 100 percent here
100 of outlets all attain the grading
from our government
uh service recovery we have a 100
percent
uh meeting our targets and of course uh
most importantly on time delivery from
our suppliers
improvement by 13 uh customer results
are very
important something that we measure in
terms of complaints
and complement ratio in terms of uh
satisfaction now this is the part
whereby we will come in using the
quantitative survey to really measure
the
measure monitor right the the all the
dimension that our customers care about
and of course most importantly is the
the market share and so forth in terms
captured and measured in terms of
brand advocacy score and very
importantly
i think it's the most important all of
these
employees result operation results
customer result comes together to
contribute to of course
very impactful financial results are
basically uh there's a
very big jump a 20 increase in revenue
yeah
yes okay of course these are not all of
it there's more results of course that
that that we have okay now finally we
shall now get to the
the the toolkit itself and the star of
the
show today and we have uh created a
digital version
of the uh the principles that we have
mentioned just now
uh those were applied in on a
non-digital
uh context yeah with our crowd so now we
have a choice to apply in the digital
format because you know with the kovit
the remote working and so forth so we'd
like to share with you
uh the flexibility of our framework okay
it can be applied also in a remote way
in a digital way right it's even easier
than plug and play
because you don't have to do anything at
all we will be
the ones doing the plug and play okay
now the
what better way to demonstrate this uh
to you
than to apply on something right so
remember
uh during your registration um you
answered the poll for us
uh and the poll was a survey on
which aspect of your employee experience
you would be most uh
keen to improve upon now we have the
results for you
and um what we gathered was
from 229 respondents
and out of the 129 respondents we have a
total of
268 responses and of
um all of those responses
we have here the highest uh
chose teamwork collaboration 44
we got more responses because each
respondent can choose more than one
choices okay
so i think with that i think we
consolidated that um
a lot of you guys most of you guys are
very very the highly voted one is
teamwork and collaboration so right now
we're going to apply
the digital 3t to this yes and see how
it goes right yes so we're going to
apply
on this so imagine um you're
we we are now consulting you on your
company and we are going to conduct this
uh
using this toolkit on this um aspect
mm-hmm your employees let's say you are
interested in really really want to
understand right what are the needs of
the employees involving teamwork and
collaboration now we share with you what
you can do okay so first step we will of
course meet up with you
and then what we will do is
we would then meet up with you to
understand
your company the employee demographics
and everything
and from there the next step would be to
craft the empathy statement
okay and the advertising statement would
be look something like this
please share with us your good and good
and or bad
experience working in a team or
collaborating with others
yeah just that's the only question
they're asking
so well i'd like to highlight here that
previously we was very very open we just
asked for your good and bad working
experiences
but right now if there is some specific
area that you want to focus on you
realize that now you can actually take
your little statement here
uh take a little instruction here when
you construct our
treaty approach so the first part when
you get them to pick pictures regarding
experience
it can be a little bit more focused in
this case we are slightly more focused
on
in terms of a team work in terms of
collaborating with others
okay so we want to share with you this
little trick whereby you can see
our treaty framework is a very gen very
very
good framework in the sense that there's
a lot of little little tweaks and
modification that you can do
that is specific to your needs so not to
worry if you
if you do not know how to craft this
statement because we will be the ones
that will come in
and to uh to do this together with you
of course if you wish to learn how to
craft it by yourself
in future yes not an issue we can also
have a separate session where
we teach you break it down how to craft
this on your own
exactly we just want to share with you
the flexibility of the these these two
key
the example here is for your employees
to send us five
photos and for each photo give us three
statements now this is
this is uh not cast in stone it can be
changed right
it can be up to 10 photos it can be six
photos yeah
right but in terms of statements we do
not recommend it to be more than three
statements
so again it really depends i think uh if
that's in discussion it really depends
on the sample size involved right yeah
yeah because the sample size will be
relating to your company size and so
forth correct so depending on the sample
size we may request each of the
participants to collect different number
of pictures
and of course for each picture we may
slightly tweak the number of statements
required usually
what is familiar with us each photo we
usually ask for three to five statements
yes so that's why we would need you
first before we craft all this
to understand the demographics of your
workforce
and the size of your workfalls and then
with all those
information we will craft this statement
so this can be done digitally you can
see
uh it could be instruction sent to the
handphone with the instruction
yes so we will create this for you okay
so this is what you will see
right they will will have a link
provided and you can use that link and
share it with
all your employees they can access it
through their phone or on their
computers
and this is how it looks like this is
actual mock-up how it will look like
okay
with your company logo as well and uh
when they click next they'll go on to
the next screen and the next screen of
course here is where they can upload
their photo
photo number one with their
corresponding three statements
then of course after this page they're
gone to of course photo number
two three so on and so forth so that is
how how how it's being done and we'll do
that for you
okay and even before we launch it live
to your employees before you even share
that link to employees
we would first have a town hall together
with you
and all your employees so this town hall
can be done virtually
or it can be done of course you know in
your company premises that is of course
uh when everything and when all this
craziness is over
of course um the town hall done in your
office premises is the most ideal is
most preferred
right that is what we would like to do
so now that is during this town hall
that's where we will feel questions from
the audience from your employees they
may have some questions
asking things like oh can we pick photos
from the internet
blah blah blah or no what if we are not
able to be in the office primaries or
whatever
so that's where that's what this town
hall is for
and uh that we would we would we would
highly encourage and we would then host
this town hall
uh together with you and then they would
then
go on and do the exercise and towards
the end
uh this is the end product of what you
would get yeah
this is a mock-up that we did just to
share with you a possible outcome
right i think all of you guys are very
curious about what are the possible
outcome or deliverables that you get you
can see of course
with this possible outcome it's a narrow
world because it's about a needs
the employees needs in order to promote
what collaboration right because that
was starting point
so these are maybe some of the possible
key clusters of need
uh one possibility we just share with
you it could be cross-level
co-creation they may need to have levels
that means
across different levels uh bottom top
leader levels right there may be a need
to form
teams involving managers from different
levels so in this
company perhaps there's a culture of
pulling right
so that's why it pops up here that the
employees are telling us oh
we need an environment where there is no
pulling of ranks in our discussion
in order to promote uh collaboration so
these are one of the needs of course
they thought you can come up with a
mechanism or some intervention
and of course uh there may be one trust
of me uh needing to have
more more involvement from the bottom
you know
participation of course there may be
different job needs
there may be also a needs that generate
you have to foster multi-generation
collaboration or work team together
and don't forget there's also needs on
the physical side the environment
you can see that in order to promote
collaboration is is
across management it could be
involvement from
the lower level people it could be some
job redesign needed
and of course uh there may be some kind
of new policies
yeah and then maybe of course some new
design of space and so forth
this is really just to share with you
this is a starting point right but
there's a lot of possibilities uh good
outcomes that can
that can result in impactful ones like
those impacts that we have shared with
you yeah although this is a sample
but uh these were actually commonly uh
occurring
clusters uh that keep popping up uh in
our projects with our previous clients
and the one that comes up uh more
prevalently
uh especially in this um era of decade
is the multi-generational work team
and we see this coming up very very much
because uh for the first time
actually in the workforce we actually
get
really a multi-generational from from
very senior
right down to the to the very young
gen y right correct and one of our
client was actually a bank of singapore
who was
uh very concerned about this and we even
embarked on a few series of uh
programs with them actually uh with
their hr
uh trying to address this arising
issue so of course uh through this
method if you die deeper you
can have a really deeper understanding
you know you may have a need for mind
set shifting there may be a need of
upscaling a risk feeling of
legacy workforce correct and of course
there may be even a need of
succession planning yes that may
actually bring the two generation
closer right and finally of course you
see
the inter-dependency of all these needs
so each cluster is no longer just a need
by itself you know
is you you can see from here how how
they are how they affect
other clusters how each one is
interdependent on each other
in order to form an ecosystem so this
will be
what you'll get if you do a qualitative
research and you can see not really
charts not only bar chart
pie chart it's more of a map whereby
they map up all the
other needs in a very visual way of
course this is just a sample
the actual uh deliverable to you or if
you embark on a project like this would
be
more extensive there will be more
literature that we would accompany this
map
to explain uh what it means for the last
bit we just want to wrap up
what we are sharing with you and how
does it compare to our the traditional
approach i think most of you guys are
familiar with okay
so one of the key thing here is our
empathy approach
focuses or emphasize on exploratory
okay you have found new things where i
discover unknown unmet needs
now this is often very difficult to
articulate from
our stakeholders so we have to have an
approach to get them to storytell
for us to really uncover ourselves yes
now traditionally i think all of you
guys i know
in singapore we are we are very very we
are taught to
do a lot of this measure and monitoring
because why statistics and numbers
give us a lot of security basically i'm
a researcher and i love statistics as
well but these are
the differences between the two approach
uh they serve different objectives
currently a lot of organizations are
using this method of course
yeah using it in an exploratory way
yeah we hope that uh every one of you
guys understand that when you use that
method
you usually don't discover new things
you pre-determine
and you predetermine things that you
want to measure what we would highly
recommend is to do this first
and then once you have identified what
the customers needs
or what what they implement the
dimensions that they focus on and then
of course you can
then you design a survey that is
focused or grounded by all those
dimensions yeah they can measure the
right things and more interacting
because i think if not you'll be wasting
a lot of resources measuring wrong
things and monitoring wrong things
left yes okay now the other very
important part is uh the empathy
approach uh you can see that
we are very very customer focused
meaning the whole process itself must be
engaging even for the customers
so when they're collecting data it
cannot be tedious it cannot be boring
and it must be all about them so i think
based on research you know when we
when we are telling stories about
ourselves we are very excited very happy
so when we are asked to talk about
companies which is not ourselves our
positivity goes a bit down and our
energy goes a bit down okay let me give
you an example
no we we come across this typical
statement a lot in a feedback
questionnaire survey
that goes like this oh please uh please
share with us
how we can improve to better serve you
right it's a very commonly heard
question right but
that one is about you know the company
correct and as a as a customer you know
i'll be
i'll be thinking that first of all i do
not work for you
i do not know your processes how can i
tell you
how to improve right however i can tell
you
what i like or what i don't like or
describe experience to you
okay so traditionally we are very
focused on a company
you know asking them about company how a
company do
how our company products do how is our
customer recover how is our customer
service and so forth
so that results in less engaging for the
customer
the best is just to ask them please
share with us your good and bad
experience shopping with us
yeah that would be that would be fun
yeah and then of course i'll make sure
that it is open-ended correct
yeah and if you do not if you don't want
to uh restrict it
to just their shopping experience at
your
company then you can do this please sure
advance your good and bad shopping
experience
full stop now they will then share with
you
their good and bad shopping experience
everywhere
and anywhere which includes your
competitors
so if you are studying shoes then you
say your good and bad experience buying
shoes
yes you'll be surprised then you'll
really see the whole journey
do they go online to buy did they go
online to check first
and then they go on to the physical
store and so forth because i think most
of you guys now that we are
trying to design a seamless kind of
journey
both online and offline yes so i think
to really understand that you have to
use the exploratory approach
to see really what kind of journey do
they take you know if you're
selling shoes just ask them no uh so you
can share with us take some pictures
about your good and bad
experience buying shoes yes that's about
it this this was this was the exact
uh project uh that we did as with chanel
one of our clients just
end of last year chanel regional office
in singapore
and the empathy statement was please
share with us
your shopping experience buying
purchasing using
fragrances and beauty products luxury
products yes
luxury products yes full stop you know
it did not even rock back to
with chanel okay the last one very
important
i think by now you should know everyone
now is focusing on what experience okay
even for empathy approach it starts off
with experience
the starting point is always good and
bad dining experience good and bad
experience buying shoes and so forth so
what we do is we start off by asking
them
experience we start off by getting them
with us the experience
and from there at the back end what do
we do we uh chop
their stories up and try to deconstruct
what contributes to their experience
so that is actually the approach that we
are sharing with you now traditionally
what we do i think by now you should
know traditionally we are trying to say
okay
dining dining experience we will
pre-determine what are the
products or services that will deliver
to the experience and we start
measuring those dimensions or measuring
those products and services
so it results in a different approach
right and rather than focusing on the
customer experience it becomes very
internal it becomes very product-based
very service-based
okay so that is actually quite
restrictive and it actually
creates a barrier for your innovation or
coming up something new
we have we have uh we have a couple of
times in the past um
dealt with clients who would tell us oh
but we are manufacturing you know we
produce stuff
we make stuff so it should be about the
product but then ask them well
where does your product or service
reside in
where do they where did they pop up they
happen in the experience of the customer
that is how and why you should focus on
the experience
it is the experience of first
knowing your product it is their
experience of
getting to hear about your product and
then the experience of
coming to contact with your product
buying your product
bringing it home unwrapping it
actually using it everything so it's
always being rocked back to the
experience so the experience is starting
point right yeah yeah it's a starting
point and it drives what kind of product
service you should be producing
so i think the starting point should
always be focusing on the customer
experience
and getting them to talk about
experience yeah so this is another
another another
uh project you know that that we do with
our client bosch
uh they are products uh a product
centric company in the past
but actually they have shifted way over
to this site
yeah good i think uh that's that's
roughly what we have
for from alfred and um me uh we are we
are very excited later on we'll be
answering some of your q and a questions
but i think all of you guys are very
very excited now regarding uh of course
this empathy approach and
then maybe even some little projects
that you may be thinking of starting
so yeah to help you kickstart so uh we
will then have michelle coming back
online to share with you some um schemes
that they may have
that will help you to launch this or use
this toolkit
thank you alfred and ken for that great
sharing so actually there's
really a lot of potential once companies
start adopting such an approach
as well as a mindset like that that
means to continuously be a tune
to meet the needs of your stakeholders
be it internal or external
so as highlighted by alfred and ken
these are actually
principles what you've just heard are
principles of design thinking
before i dive into the specifics for
about the schemes for smes just a bit of
a shout out for our
design support council we've actually
been around since 2003
and were the proud national agency in
singapore championing the growth of the
design sector here
so really our ultimate vision is to help
singapore become
an innovation driven economy as well as
a livable city by design
by 2025. so when i say design
it's design meaning anything that range
from
classical disciplines like graphic
design fashion design
product design architecture all the way
to emerging design disciplines like
experience design
what um often in canada chat service
design as well as design strategy
so as the design console we understand
the importance
of using the design thinking approach
for businesses
and so we have recently rolled out
schemes in collaboration with
enterprise singapore esg for short
around the use of
user journey mapping for smes if you
like the approach you heard earlier from
both of them
and you wish to use this for your
business you would definitely find this
game very useful for you
this scheme is the user journey mapping
scheme
depending on your budget as well as your
appetite we're offering three different
variations of what we call
the ugms for short two companies
subsidizing up to 80
of the course so in each of these
options
you have the choice to work with your
preferred design consultants
canon alfred being one of them uh with
option one
it is uh it is for companies who have uh
customer facing
clients who want a quick understanding
of your current
customer journey so you're looking at
your existing customers and then this is
sort of limited to that one persona
which is going to be in that deliverable
that
that the consultant will give to you
whereas in
option two will be a slightly more
extensive version
covering up to three to four personas
for businesses who are
thinking of reaching out to potentially
new customer segments
on top of your existing customer
segments and in option three
apart from surveying your external
stakeholders aka your customers
this option also takes you through how
your internal back-end operations
staff actions or how all of that will
affect your external
customers so you're looking at that
entire process
in this option the consultant will be
delivering an entire service design
blueprint
something which was also highlighted by
canon offered earlier
that blueprint will help to map out all
that various internal and external touch
points
how they're working together how they're
not working together and
ultimately how that affects your
business outcomes so
just to give your a little bit of
visualization to these options right
option one and two
basically you're targeting at people who
are your external customers right that's
where you put out your products
the front stage area whereas in option
three you're looking at the whole broad
range
from your back end behind the scenes all
the way to the front
stage uh um happenings so that's some uh
clarity on the various options that i've
just shared
just like to move on to this last slide
a service that we get
is rail this is also highlighted in the
bain research eighty percent of
organizations believe that they
delivered a superior experience to their
customers
but only eight percent of customers feel
that way so actually this statement
also applies to how employers assume
they think they are treating their
employees the way they want to be
treated
so just to end off employees are your
greatest assets
don't assume what they want but always
try to find out what they actually need
or they desire to fulfill on their jobs
especially in times like that like what
um ken and alfred have shared
when the company takes care of your
employees or their employees
the employees will take care of the
company so thank you very much
uh we've come to the end of our
presentation and
now we'll be taking the uh questions we
will start with the questions around the
empathy toolkit
now uh i think i'd like to share with
you uh the focus here because it's like
maybe sometimes uh the company's my site
is always thinking that we're asking the
customer what they want and so forth
but right now we're just asking about
their good and bad experiences
we are not asking uh what they want we
are actually at the back end
trying to uncover their needs and we
will design something that
that aligns to their needs but if i if i
understand your question correctly it
says here
as the approach is more customer set
driven sometimes clients
might be a little insistent on the
direction
focusing from their point of view right
now
that is precisely what we want we want
to hear
the customer's point of view you see
yeah so we would let them tell us
exactly what they want to say
from their heart that's why we say it's
empathy by by
hearing what they want to say yeah i
mean
so from there letting them say all they
want to say
we just gather it then on the back end
we would then dissect it analyze it to
understand oh
why are you understand their point of
view so the whole idea of this empathy
tool
is to extract their point of view which
we would normally unable to do using a
quantitative uh method uh or
quantitative style of surveying
yeah so that is the power of this
particular uh this particular right and
also the approach is also not truly
uh customer driven it can be employee
driven
because a an employee is also your
internal customer so if we if we if we
tweak
we shift our mindset a little bit and
treat the employee
also as a customer but an internal one
that same principle and the same tool
can also be applied
on employees and then it is their
point of view which is the golden nugget
that we are looking for
correct yes yeah so i think holistically
i think yeah alfred
done a good job explaining holistically
uh there's a balance because there's
another stage called the ideation stage
the ideation stage actually involved all
the employees from the
employee point of view how to really
deliver the whole product's
whole system to satisfy the customer
needs and also um the other thing that
we would like to
further clarify with you here is uh you
mentioned
here how do you find a balance and
strike a midpoint
to satisfy both ends when you say both
ends
which is which is the other end that you
are referring to may i know
as alison has already said regarding the
business owners and internal customer i
think
alfred made a very good point
holistically speaking of course
we have the empathy study for the
customers right and of course
you do remember that we do also share
about the involvement about the
employees
so if it is between the business owner
versus internal customers which is
employees
so what you do is um this tool will be
conducted on
internal customers your employees okay
we'll gather
all their uh viewpoints point of views
and then from there we would then
analyze it dissect it and cluster it and
present this this needs map
for the business owner to have a very
clear view
you know of what the employees are
sharing their employee point of view
from there
the business owner that of course as
consultants we would then
from that needs met from our analysis
offer our recommendations
to the business owner to help the
business owner
um uh assimilate and find that balance
to students to bring the two viewpoints
his
viewpoint and their viewpoint together
to
to strike the balance yeah that's how we
do it yeah
i think yeah i think in summary is a
multi-stakeholder kind of approach
okay all stakeholders are actually uh
involved
thank you i hope we have answered your
question alison you can email us uh if
you want we can have some business case
to show you also
basically i think it's really really
holistic we start with uh external
internal customer of course afraid
shared we have the empathy study and we
can also
do through the involvement and
co-creation with the
employees right their point of view is
also factored in
when we design the the delivery of the
products and services
with wang cafe we applied on both we
applied
that tool on the external customers as
well as internal customers
so this way both parties get to share
their point of view
and then both party uh employees get to
see
and get to also then you know find that
balance and
that balance is where all the
solutioning comes about now i'd like to
answer the question regarding
quantitative data used together with
qualitative data
okay now basically uh as we have also
shared in the
in our presentation right they are both
very useful
they are distinctively used to achieve
different objectives
so uh yeah so for for qualitative as i
mentioned a small discovery
and you always get a very descriptive
analysis
that allows you to also explain your
quantitative data sometimes
so we also have done that whereby you do
a survey you got very low rating for
your cleanliness for example right
so you can use qualitative data to
really understand what is the rating for
your
your kindness so low and then you can
even use pictures
no to really tag to the number if they
give you rating too then you can look at
the pictures
wow this is rating too so i think that
that that makes the numbers comes to
life like not
a rating tool for cleanliness different
people got different perspective
so i think with qualitative data you
will be able to see
visually what is a rating of two you can
also be able to see what kind of words
being used to describe a rating too
so i think there's a lot of opportunity
for combining both
methods and they complement each other
correct
correct did you answer your question
okay we hope we did we have conducted
this we have conducted this digitally
um the the first business case that we
shared today
that was uh conducted digitally in
singapore
with a local sme and with half of their
workforce
working from home and half on premise
yeah
and they actually have a few branches as
well
spread out in singapore so that is uh
and it's still ongoing actually
and then the we also have some other
clients that we've conducted just
digitally as well most recently would be
with chanel
chanel singapore and chanel regional
office
based in singapore now that was done on
a bigger scale with
their employees across the
front of line employees that means
employees that you will see
on the front line in the boutiques as
well as
employees in the office across various
functions
because they were trying to achieve a
multi-collaborative
kind of a culture uh in the company
and uh so that was done pretty uh
exciting
in terms of challenge um i wouldn't say
there was any challenge
uh because what we did was we we
we had a town hall we fielded questions
um so therefore that's why that that
reduced the
challenge the digital one also
um there wasn't any challenge at all it
was very smooth
i think yeah everybody took to it like
like ducks and water
it's pretty popular i think that there's
everybody love to have all this picture
taking
uploading downloading i think they have
no issues i think the fun element was
there
it was it was really about them
yeah i think that that's really key yes
that was really key
and then the other question that
exercise took us
about actually um half a month
uh which is two weeks to a month uh it
is done pretty
pretty um very uh succinctly uh
depending on the size
of your workforce and of course the
demographics and of course
um uh what actually you would like to
focus on
and also taking into consideration um
maybe certain challenges that you want
to um be able to
iron out or certain things that you want
to see you know from this exercise so
we will then come in and work with the
client
to um to to craft this um
to scope um this design spring with them
uh to find out uh the best solution for
them
yeah it depends on how how extensive
they want it to be yeah so i think uh
that's pretty
open uh really really uh dependent on
the needs of the company
yeah of course uh the design singapore
council has different different uh
schemes to support uh different scopes
right
yeah so um
uh are you referring to um asking that
question
using our tool so i'm answering you in
that
in that in that understanding okay so if
you want to use the tool
that we have introduced to you and the
question that we
might most most probably ask would be
you know make sure to give us your
good and bad experience um working from
home
um i will most i may suggest good and
bad working experience
in this kovic 19 situation
okay so maybe they again it's more of
just really listening to their stories
and then you have to group it and
underlyingly tease out anything that is
being mentioned regarding their morale
so you notice we did not use the word
morale we did not directly say
how is your morale no we would we we
would go
with how uh please share advance your
good and bad experience
working from home or your good and yes
if it is work that you you want to you
know relate to
but if it is more than work then just
you know please share advance your good
and bad experience during this period
um you know whatever so i mean if you
want to
yeah and compass the correct bigger
picture yeah
yeah but do not no you don't have to use
the word for real and don't go to morale
yes
yeah but it's easy for them to tell you
my experience yeah
working from home all you can say yeah
that's why i first say you're good
your your experience of discovery 19
experience what kind of experiences are
you
undergoing you know it's pretty open
they may talk about their life they talk
about their book everything so i think
if you want a broader one just says
what is the good and bad experience
undergoing this uh
crisis or this situation that could be
suggestion yeah i think that could be
the starting point yeah the the morale
part
is not exactly and really for them to
tell us but
for us to analyze correct based on them
telling us their experience
for example we have a few clients right
so we were just
we were just online a little bit early
before the session and then we just saw
chat
and we were we were asking around some
of the employees oh how are you guys
so some of them will share with us very
openly oh yeah a bit harder
because everyone is at home no one very
stressful so
from things like this stressful certain
certain statements yeah
you know we we can then
you know extract it to to have an
understanding about their morale
so those are the indicators but if you
ask them to tell you directly
about morale yeah a bit too narrow
yeah yeah okay thanks i hope you
answered
now maybe i can just share with you
about this ministry shopping
no there's a lot of flexibility of
course uh we for the main cafe right
they actually went
down and they take photos about their
great and bad dining experiences
right uh in this cove situation right uh
remember that the photo
is just a trigger so we haven't even
tried to get them to just uh grab some
pictures digitally yeah from the
from the internet
okay regarding their good and bad
dynamic experience for example or
experience about buying shoes so we get
them to grab from the internet and then
from there right from the picture itself
right
we get them to describe their experience
so there's one possibility
so you can see that for the three t's
right the first t is about a three girl
that
encapsulate the experience it could be
of course
the best you go there to take photos or
you could get them to get pictures from
the internet
or we may have tried creating photos you
know like a museum
physically you know it's an event so we
have all
pictures croatian like an event
like a like even like a museum we get
them to come and then they just take
pictures
and then even put uh book
statements i'm posting no i put on
pictures as well so i think there are
many possibilities
so think about it in a broader way uh
the treaties
so therefore it is not uh restricted to
um you know i think that's where we are
taking photos i mean
that's one possibility so that's why the
um the town hall
is is is good also it helps to fill
questions like this
um in our past projects uh this this
question pop up
quite uh regularly so that's where we
then explain to
them you know oh yes i know you are
currently at home take for example smb
service okay you're asking
a customer to participate to give you
their good and bad experience about fme
service
so you can still do is do this even
though it's kobe 19
you know so i'm sure there will be those
who don't go out
to tap out so they will order food
delivery so they can
they can already buy that itself they
can take the pictures you know they can
take the screenshot of how easy
how difficult it is to go online to go
to footpanthers website blah blah blah
and they can also uh take pictures and
show you pictures about how long they
weigh
you know or it could be oh when the when
when the
when the food delivery guy arrives
instead of pressing the doorbell
they go and bang the door or things like
that those are pictures that they can
they can do so so all these things can
give you a very rich
information about things and even
education let's say
we have a we have two clients who are in
the education field
uh the enrichment center quite quite
quite big right
so what they did was um because we we
did a
uh we did a knowledge transfer project
with them so they know how to do it
themselves
what they did was they really they have
so much care
for their students but they realize that
the actual
real real customer is not students per
se but the students
parents you see so they got their
parents involved sharing
pictures of their ups and downs their
challenges having their kids study from
home
as well as them working from home clash
space issue so they shed so much rich
data
yeah so to
consciously sustain this in fact even
before covet 19 we have been doing this
already
with with our clients and in fact this
is something that
we have to consciously put into our
calendar
as a company you know to do at least
once a year
uh to do as a pulse check
as a pulse check with with our customers
as well as our employees
because that would then guide us in
whatever surveys with whatever
things that we want to measure moving
forward i mean we cannot be
just i mean doing business and working
you know without ever getting a pulse
check right so one of the conscious
way to do this would be to you know uh
uh discipline ourselves and put it in
our corporate calendar
that you know we pick a period a of
downtime
in our calendar where there is no uh
budget ending
and things like the end of financial
year reporting away from all the agms
and stuff like that
yeah uh pick a date um what we
always like to recommend is to conduct
this exercise
prior to your annual retreat
all right be it a company-wide retreat
or be
your c-suite retreat um a lot of
companies who engaged us to do this for
their c-suite
would always like to do this exercise
prior to their annual c-suite retreat
so that when the c-suite comes together
for that annual retreat
they then have all this data rich
visual driven image driven data to help
them
during that retreat so the retreat is no
longer just about climbing trees
and pulling tuck of walls and stuff like
that so this can be quite fun
because we will do the tedious
groundwork for them
gathering all these pictures and all
this data and all these
needs met and then at the retreat they
will do the fun part
the coming up with ideas to solve this
part to solve that
part or to refine the whole journey map
those are very fun activities
to be done during your retreat so that's
how we can conscientiously
make it such that you know it happens
once a year
at least
so of course the the first and best and
easiest way is to
dangle a reward of course so with uh
wang cafe
uh they have their loyalty card program
or stored value card program
so what they did was they had uh they
prepared i think uh
30 or so cards each one with the value
of 30 dollars
but but but then they were very afraid
that they may not get actual customers
so what they did was
with that special project we went one
step
further and employed a team of mystery
diners of course you must make them
design
the empathy study in such a way that
it's very very easy for the customers to
do
and of course uh if it's a bit difficult
then maybe you even
need to get uh get them to persuade by
making it like getting them to only
contribute one pictures perhaps that's
one photo and some statements
of course then you have to approach more
and more customers and so forth
so i think there is a flexibility in
designing
the process to make sure that it is a
very
easy very simple for for your customers
to participate
so with with mystery customer of course
we will have to do
the uh um alignment of their
demographics
to the company's actual and if your
actual customer
is unable to participate right uh you
you can
actually get uh other people who are
representative or have the same
demographics
oh the word came to me sorry is the
proxy customer
you can use that too we have done proxy
before
yeah proxy customers because sometimes
the customers are too busy and things
like that we we do the proxy
that's possible oh you did it for wealth
it was for a wealth management company
yeah for welfare
yeah so yeah so so their clients are
really the shishi
high network ultra high net worth
we wouldn't have time to take yeah you
know so so the client was a bit
sensitive in reviewing all these high
net worth
names but we did a proxy correct yeah so
we do
proxy for that so that's one possibility
think about that correct but the
demographics have to be
very very low yeah very like in terms of
personality
interests hobbies whatever and yeah and
the good thing about qualitative
research the sample size
you know it's not like 100 or 200
that's a good correct correct you don't
need a big sample size
to really conduct the processes so now
that is b to c right some companies they
they have a loyalty program and uh and
when they reach into their loyalty
program database
these are their fans now they
it is good to always tap on this this
group of customers
yes do not be misled that oh there your
fans who are
they will tell you what all the good
things about you no
in fact fans are more than happy to tell
you what they do not like
because why fans wish you
to always be there because they like you
you they want you to always be there see
so that they can keep on buying from you
they can keep on using your services
that is what we realize about about
about this so you can always tap on your
um your loyalty your database of loyal
customers that's
one and uh if it's a b to b
even easier b to b same thing you know
uh what we do is we will always tag it
with the sales person
the sales manager the sales engineers
so each sales engineer will always have
a very good customer a bunch of good
customers
so that's where we tack along so the
sales engineer or the sales
executive will become the middle person
but they will not be involved
during the actual uh study they would
just
uh open the door for us yes so then
we'll do the rest so it always works all
the time
we have done this in in the in the
engineering field as well so that's why
it's very important to have this
conversation with us
so that when we once we understand the
demographics
of your audience then we can be able to
advise you how to do it because we have
already applied it
from many versions of it from super high
end
right down to the across all industries
yeah right down to the mom-and-pop
things you know i used to work for ritz
carlton i opened the capella singapore
so for us each time before we opened a
hotel we need to do this
actually but back then we don't have
these tools
so when i was still working for the ritz
i didn't realize that oh
actually i'm already doing this back
then you know so we were doing this with
our
of course loyal customers in our
database so it was much easier
and it wasn't done with pictures
statements it was done
in inviting them over giving them a free
weekend stay
and while they are with us and we will
find pockets of time
to bump into them to come to start
little conversations and for them to
reveal
things to us yeah so there's many ways
of doing it yeah
very flexible yes okay
i think thank you everyone for your
questions are we gonna have any more
questions if that's
um the last question then this is our
last slide
so we hope they've gained some valuable
insights on how you can better
understand your employees i think we're
getting some feedback as well from the
participants that
you know the sharing was very useful
they are now able to know how to better
rephrase their questions to
help their team elicit more responses
and then hopefully
provide more insights for their own
companies so on your screen right now
you will see this qr code you can scan
the qr code to
get a copy of the slides that we have
shared today and if you have further
questions with regards to anything at
all
anybody took it all the schemes you can
reach out to these emails
stated on the slides thank you again
everybody we hope you have enjoyed this
session as much as we have enjoyed
putting this together for you
um and we look forward to uh organizing
more sessions for you
if you'd like to stay ahead of news
around the use for design please also
visit our design singapore linkedin page
and be sure to follow us to stay tuned
for more of such webinars
so with that i like to thank everyone
and hope you guys have a great weekend
ahead
and stay safe thank you thank you bye